JASON SILVA: I think that one
of the things that we enjoy
the most as human beings
is to lose ourselves
in an experience,
to find ourselves
in a situation in which
the gravity of the moment,
the weight of the now, is so
powerful that we find ourselves
outside ourselves.
You become what you
behold, so to speak,
so that our neurotic,
inner critic--
the voice in our head
that is nagging us,
anxious about the future
or saddened by the past,
paralyzed by the past--
instead goes silent,
and there is grace
in this moment.
The weight of the now in all
of its gravity and splendor--
particularly in a
preconfigured, epic context--
can serve to purge
you of your angst.
This is a transformative
experience.
I think when I come to a
place like this, whenever
I put myself outside myself,
I am able to pierce the veil.
I am able to see beyond my
concerns and my constraints,
and I connect with something
larger than myself.
It's something that
we can all relate to.
we seek out, right?
And these moments, these
moments do something to us
that is medicinal, right?
This is existential medication.
We address the existential
panic, the ontological panic,
and we push it out of our minds.
Death goes from being
an imminent panic
to a deferrable abstraction.
Thoughts of mortality
dissipate, and we
get to inhabit some kind of
eternal now-- immortality
now as we smash our sense
of separateness in temples
of fragmentation in what
Alan Harrington called
a form of electronic Buddhism.
It doesn't matter if it's
the rave concert or Burning
Man or an opera theater or
an IMAX screen or an epic
ocean-- the point
being these vistas,
these contexts, these stages
become rites of passage,
transformative experiences,
moments of reconciliation.
We slay the dragon,
we move forth,
and then the angst is
gone, at least temporarily.